all right and we are live yo nobody's
killing me with the case
welcome
to the last word with laura cognito
ibontis and the amazing thai guy travis
what is going on gentlemen let's start
with start with trav first what's going
on with you sir how are you doing yeah
i'm doing good man i've been working on
uh back-to-back reviews finished i am
fish now i'm working on that game sable
uh that i'll
have a review up of next week it comes
out next week and uh yeah just keeping
busy i haven't gotten to play a lot of
games that i've been seeing everybody
freak out about death loop is super high
on my list i really want to get some
time with that i still haven't caught up
with uh
uh psychonauts two i still haven't even
opened that game on my dashboard so my
backlog is super long and growing and
i'm really worried about what this fall
is gonna do to it uh how about you e
uh let's see i've played about five six
hours of death loop
it has its hooks in me deep man it's
just a lot of fun now i've never played
an arcane game i've never played
dishonored so i know i've missed out
really yes no way so whoa don't feel me
don't feel bad we eat we should
i've heard really really good things
about like the movement and the level
design and stuff like that and i don't
know if the level design would be quite
as much as i heard about dishonored 2
some like
weird rotating church house thing
there's something i remember hearing
about that in there that's crazy but
just
i don't know from watching new rads tell
me he played dishonored one there's a
teleport move that you can eventually
get and it just it feels really smooth
gunplay is actually pretty on point i'm
playing on pc which had some bugs but i
kind of like verified the installation
seems to be good now um
overall it just is a fun sandbox to toy
around in and the more you kind of learn
they had some nice quality of life
things in there i'm trying not to give
away too much
um
we lost snowman and we lost our guest
reconfigure reconfigure figure i'll take
over sorry
we move forward he's he's in the right
position
he's in a square
[Laughter]
was talking just talking about that but
anyway still talking about death loop
yeah death loop's fun i missed out i
haven't played fist yet for ps5 i really
that one looks good there's a lot as i
said i agree with you travis uh the
backlog is growing i swear by the minute
ken is next week it's just going to be
crazy so you guys need to play
dishonored like oh my god dude i know
arcane is
hurricane is low-key one of the best
developers in the world literally
which is i'm sorry you're right because
i literally podcast my definitely
because is like the lord of arcade and
he he like kills me he's like you got a
platinum like i know dude seriously arc
all right like
that's why it was such a big move when
xbox bought bethesda's because they're
getting some of the best developers in
the world arcane is super underrated as
a studio playground games like they're
kind of consolidating a lot of the
really good uh
developer teams but yeah arcane games
are amazing
before we go too far we have an amazing
guest with us so i've got to introduce
them so let's get to it
welcome to the last word episode number
166 marasov and savithoon are currently
playing their game of chess while we
move like pawns in the system we may
think we know the conclusion to this
story but the journey still has most of
us rather intrigued speaking of journeys
crucible has been through a bumpy one
for a while now but last weekend was
something special records were broken
saint 14 probably lost his voice and
loot showered guardians from the
proverbial heavens in a week where
crucible is such an important topic our
guest is a perfect one to join us at the
campfire this week if you listen to his
videos you might picture him you might
picture sherlock holmes and you wouldn't
be that far off honestly with his deer
stalker hat pipe in hand as he adjusts
his glasses and prepares to speak the
words he uses
you you know will be articulated in a
way that confirms intelligence but if
you listen he conveys all points of any
topic in a way that feel as though a fog
has been lifted and new light can be
seen on the horizon
you can't explain why after watching one
of his videos you are now driven to
improve yourself and yet filled with a
sense of calm at the same time ready to
tackle what lies ahead but not exactly
sure why your perspective may have
changed was it the words he said or just
the way he said it with that smooth asmr
sound and brilliant accent
did i have a grand epiphany or did
someone just pour in perform an
inception in my mind you may have found
our guest by a video tweet or live game
play review you've likely taken a moment
to change the way you play destiny after
consuming his content
if you don't find him in destiny putting
in methodical work for shacks or saint
he is likely playing car soccer at a
very high level because of course
anything with a high skill ceiling
intrigues this man so whether you roll
in scrub mentality 101 iron banner 212
or movement 316 i highly suggest you
attend one of this man's lectures the
man with the phd in destiny the one and
only crucible doctor ascendant nomad how
are you doing this evening sir
put your guy
very good and that was quite the
introduction i have to say um
my answer is yes i will marry you
that was pretty good
i should i wish i i did that to my
girlfriend like gave her that kind of
speech and that sort of info
because jesus christ
i'm allowed to say that right now
yeah yeah we made it past the first 30
seconds on youtube you're you're good
we're good what's going on brother how
you doing
yeah really really good um
it's been a really good week for for
destiny it's been a really good week for
crucible this season is going from
strength to strength to strength and
it's
getting really really interesting
narratively
as well but i'm just very happy that
that not only did crucible get the
revamp it deserved or well part of
crucible got the revamp it deserved
but the communication surrounding it has
also been fairly consistent and has been
fairly open um
so i'm i'm really excited to see where
it goes from here and i'm really excited
to see how it is sustained over the next
you know five months or so
definitely definitely man good to have
you here man
always a pleasure i i love your videos
the the the comedic timing the uh they
just did this the know-how of pvp it
always makes me smile brings me joy to
watching no man videos so it's good to
have you back and we got to get into it
a lot of stuff going on e like what's
going on with this game this week man
talk to us i mean if you unless you're
living under a rock a very specific
playlist exploded this weekend
with literally record players for almost
all of the franchise people of different
contentions whether it was trials of the
nine or d1 basically nearly a record
weakened if it wasn't depending on what
record you're comparing it to and that
was trials of osiris which we've all
been saying has been nearly dead mode
half baked all of those things and
finally
bungie's just like all right we're gonna
do everything all at once at the same
time anything we figure out we're gonna
hit next week and the week after which
we'll get to
i mean
the fact that i played 70 matches this
weekend and i have opinions about all of
those wow
more than i probably have ever played
like trials possibly ever
wow so i mean i've been carried probably
in d1 i got carried to a lighthouse hard
carry um in d2 i dabbled a little i
didn't even play trials and then i don't
think but in d2 like probably played
once or twice here maybe with friends
got to like three wins for a little bit
but literally haven't been flawless and
i still haven't which is fine
um but i played a lot it's it's an
interesting grind i'll have you know
opinions about some stuff but overall
the fact that i can
go in
no matter whitney hour who i'm with or
otherwise definitely gives life to a lot
of different things what about you guys
since i took the stage in the wrong time
the non-crucible guy went first i'm out
of the way now the important people
it was interesting because um you know
obviously we had a lot of discussion
here you know travis and i and stuff
like that and i understood travis's
concerned i know this is gonna feel like
oh this is the attack the jump travis
show this is not that
this is the experiences of you know he
had he had legitimate concerns and i i
respected that at the other day for me i
said i'm gonna do something different
you know i always attempt to play trials
with my three squad and we we promptly
get smashed all the time and i'm like
i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna
purposely play
solo the entire weekend just to truly
see how that experience is and it was
interesting like you know the first
couple of matches i felt like okay
people were kind of on my skill level
for the most part i felt like i was kind
of the best player which is weird which
is that that does not happen a lot and i
felt like 80 percent of my matches were
i was the best guy right and there were
times where i clutched up and did some
things i put some highlights out on
twitter that i wasn't even amazed so to
me it just showed okay
the the pool is larger because if who
i'm playing with i'm the best guy out of
everything of both teams i got a couple
of ggs from uh from opposing teams or
some clutch ups i did and things like
that and some engagement some some
clutch quality resins and stuff like
that so that was good as the car went on
i would say the only time i felt a
little
weirdness was probably like right when i
got to about five or six wins because
then i started to see my opponents
the majority of the time were a two
stack or a three stack and i'm like damn
okay that's not necessarily fair it's
because i know those guys are
communicating i could tell their
movement their placement on the map and
those matches were struggling i never
went flawless the entire weekend but i
did get the seven i'll be honest i was i
was proud of my floor at seven i i put
the i put the tweet up i got my reed's
regret you know um i i think what it did
for me is the 50 round thing
is a mental game changer because if
you're not good at pvp
it's like okay
just win some rounds just win some
rounds stick in there you're okay to me
when it was the you know flawless of
bust and that's it for every skill level
the people at the bottom bro i'm it's so
demoralizing to get smashed the very
first man you're not stepping in there
you're like yo they're saying for me and
i'll be honest i'm guilty of it and i'm
an above average slightly above every
pvp player right so
it mentally crushes me when i was like
oh man i love trials so to see that with
the round changing that help then you
get your little rewards and stuff like
that i love the focus engrams with
saying that is really cool just being
able to specifically target specific
things and weapons i wanted and yeah
overall i also i thought i got to shout
them out on the mats i'm i was always
against them with low materials you know
when i play a nightfall i'm getting
showered with prisms and all this other
stuff but pvp which i love i'm like
where's this is the most competitive
thing going so overall like i said great
experience i thought for the most part
they knocked it out ninety percent of
the way we'll get into the stuff
improvement later but quickly you know i
thought it was i was happy man i to see
so many people on my friends list and it
says trials of all stars my favorite
game mode of old like i was happy y'all
like it just felt good to see the
community show out and people listen
king david got a [ __ ] i know i saw
like king david like like for me there
was apollo i was a little jealous i got
frank's i still haven't got flawless
but to see i haven't ever been flawless
i've never been flawless so like and d1
once but like to see king and this is a
guy that would step in there one time
get smashed and say hell no i'm a pve
main i'm never going back to see him
there and put that thing up proudly on
twitter that's what it is and last part
i'll say is mercury's made a good point
it's you have to is all the cash is
gonna go flawless no right
are people in the elite you know some
people feel like it may be devalued i i
understand that to a level but to me
that playing field has not changed you
can still
play i'll get to it yeah we'll get to it
to me if you are a guy who wants to go
flawless you play the elite of the elite
and what i like is that those guys get
to
once they go flawless
technically play keep continue on their
flawless card against other people with
that with that skill set so
that to me still has not changed the
thing to me which is great is that
a whole batch of people that would never
play the mode are now playing and the
mode survives so
sorry travis the numbers speak for
themselves bro it just it just does that
that's just what it is you can't deny it
now you can say well more people are
going raw people are going flawless that
you know
minimizes mine i guess if you feel so
but to me it's a weak argument at the
end of the day
okay well at the end of the day the way
you've played previously in trials
before you still can play now nothing
has you can still match make and you can
still play against other teams and
that's my final point so i'll let chav
go
yeah so obviously i have a lot of
thoughts on this because uh this week
the entire internet was hitting me up
telling me that i'm wrong because lots
of people were playing trials and i have
to say like
i i i think i said on the show like 10
times that i thought all the changes
they were making to trials were good
except i had concerns about matchmaking
and i think all of the other stuff cross
play pumping up the numbers
the system being more rewarding getting
rid of the special ammo carrying over
from round around so the rich don't get
richer and the poor get poorer all the
little changes all the changes big and
small that they made i think were hugely
beneficial and of course matchmaking was
beneficial to increasing player numbers
but the thing i said was
that i was worried that if they added
matchmaking the experience that was
previously trials of going in with a
team of three who are all communicating
playing against other teams that are
sweaty three on three is essentially
going to be gone and it's not really
going to be trials anymore and i stand
by that i think that's still true and i
think that what this has shown is that
try destiny doesn't really have an
endgame activity for pvp players anymore
right now
i played this weekend i did one card i
was casually playing with people i've
never gone flawless with before and we
destroyed every team we ran up against
on our first card and went flawless it
was really not much of a of a
competitive uh landscape so i i think
it's i i like i said i think all of this
is good i just think that there needs to
be
an endgame activity for pvp and i don't
know if trials is that anymore because
of all the changes they're making i
think it can it it's sort of like
you know raids were
too high of a barrier of entry so they
made dungeons instead right trials feels
like dungeons to me now where it's sort
of end game but it's not really the most
exciting i guess the highest tier and i
was like i heard this somewhere else and
i wanted to ask trials is i get what
you're going for 3v3 only
if there was a popular if the population
was bigger but was still all teams of
three there's still basically a
statistical chance that you're gonna go
through and have the experience that you
did with your team of people that you
know don't really sync together too well
because there's gonna be a big enough
population
even if they're threes or match made
that there are going to be some good and
bad three stacks some play together more
whether you look up on lfg
it doesn't really matter the way the
threes come into the match
matchmaking or not matchmaking if i go
to lfg and i'm like hey do you guys want
to play communication is one thing
and that will definitely give people an
advantage just if three people are
talking three aren't but the fact that
there's going to be a disparity in skill
levels with a large population means
there are going to be times
that
you are going to be facing teams that
are below a normal skill level just
because there's so many people in there
and believe me i got stomped a lot and i
can vouch for the other side of that but
i was just saying a big population is
still going to give more people a chance
especially if you like you are going to
be on a higher end but you're going to
probably stop more people than you did
before so
yeah i just i just like like i said like
i'm i don't think any of the changes
they made are bad i don't think it's bad
that more people are pink trials i don't
think that it devalues my experience if
more people go flawless i think that's a
stupid argument my thing is just that
for the people like me who want that
like
premium ultra competitive experience
that doesn't exist in destiny right now
that's all that's all i'm saying there
isn't there isn't that experience they
need to separate the playlist they need
to make a ranked system where there's
you know platinum gold like lots of
other games do there needs to be
something else so that players can talk
about that one can do that
i'll let nobody go before i go so i'm
gonna
completely annoy cog with this i think
travis is completely on the money here i
think he's correct let's go i think he's
absolutely correct
the thing is trials
it was it was marketed and it was
paraded around and it was
presented very much like a carnival it's
like yo this is a big thing happening
and it's new and it's in town and it's a
huge thing come on down there's gonna be
prizes for everybody it's like going up
to a carnival
um attraction and you know shooting the
the things on the shelf and then you
know you might miss some but you might
win some and it's just supposed to get
people in through the door and get
people interested in the idea
of playing pvp
now we really didn't don't have that we
have the iron iron banner was the is the
only other thing that
gets any sort of attention from bungie
with respect to pvp and it is
really bad
like
it's it's got a completely outdated rng
token system it is um very very
the matchmaking has a mind of its own
the
the actual game mode is arguably it is
quicker than normal control but it
doesn't iterate upon it or make it
interesting enough to make you want to
play it the only reason
90 of people play iron banner is for
pinnacles and if they're chasing for uh
a particular role like of the p-spawn
sidearm which by the way is s
as hell yes
i'm sort of video sir videos fire yes
um so
you know like like so so the way i see
it the way i see this whole trash thing
is that
we need people to be excited about pvp
again because nobody cares there hasn't
been
any reason outside of your own innate
desire to go and play
pvp there's no reason in-game story-wise
narratively in lore any reason to go
inside pvp and it's felt very neglected
for a long time so trials comes around
because it's the thing everybody knows
it's supposed to be this uber sweaty
thing but they've changed it to be very
accessible they've changed it to allow
lots of lots of people into the playlist
and they're showering loot people
getting ascendant shots like they've
never seen before people getting uh you
know rapid hit desperado messengers even
though they've never dared set foot in
trials before and i think this is all
good because it
it's put into destiny 2 the one thing
that sits that has been missing this
entire time
which is consistent positive
reinforcement
there hasn't been
anything in destiny aside from your own
desire to go out there and improve
there's been no reason to do it
and you know
just on a personal bias level it's like
my content is surrounded around
improvement and there's a very good
reason why i haven't grown as fast as i
would like
um
i love it
people don't care but with trials you
know you give people the carrot on the
stick except the stick is quite short
and you say hey isn't that carrot really
tasty
well guess what in which queen fingers
crossed
here's
all the different ranking systems in
competitive we have full competitive
rework
let's just bring in the rocket league
ranking system we started bronze we end
up in like
diamond platte
uh
super sonic league all that grand
champion sorry
and basically you wet the appetite again
you get people to think about pvp as not
a joke
anymore that it is for the every person
and trials is the carnival trousers is
supposed to be fun but if you really
want to sweat your balls off that's what
competitive's for and right now
competitive isn't that so we're left
with trials and trials being the end
game experience i agree with travis it
doesn't feel like that at all question i
need for both of you who say that is not
the end game experience the competitive
experience i need what the parameters
would be for both of you to say okay
this makes it competitive is it a skill
based matchmaking aspect is it what
about
the way trials is configured now
makes it no longer
uh is it just strictly because it's mad
because in my opinion travis feels it's
matchmaking the fact that matchmaking is
in and that teams are not set these are
his words that teams are not in teams of
three communicating right
that that takes away from the hardcore
sweater experience so my my challenge to
that is then what
makes it that what it does it have to
have matchmaking for it to be that that
that's my question what defines that
do you want to go first
yeah um
for me i think
it it is always going to be a little bit
trivialized when you compare it to other
competitive aspects because it's a ludu
shooter fundamentally and the carrot on
the end of the stick is ornaments you
know like guns that sort of thing so the
primary reason why anybody would play it
would be
for those rewards um
but i think the biggest thing that would
like the reason why i think trials is
not competitive right now
is because
it's really really hard to say this
it's really
i need just a minute just to get the
words no that's the only part i'm trying
to understand because it's like for me
it's like i agree with ibottus in the
sense that if the player pool is bigger
right then the sweaties the best of the
best are gonna more likely match up
against average to low average people
thus they're going to stop but they are
the you know you guys are the creme de
la creme so to speak so if more people
are involved then that's naturally going
to happen see my thing is so this is
this is my last point that's my last one
the elite can't have it both ways the
elite can't say there's not enough
people playing trials
and and then i'm mad because i'm going
against sweaties and all i'm going up
against other sweaties right but when
the player place is increased they can't
get mad at saying well i'm crushing
people it's it's casual now no it's
because i'm not facing other sweaties
you can't get them away yeah no i'm
personally not fussed about that i've
figured it out in my head i think trials
is not competitive is because i don't
feel like i've become a better player by
spending a whole weekend in there and i
feel like i should if i'm spending a
weekend a full weekend over 150 matches
plus
playing a playlist i should feel like i
got better i didn't okay and the and i
would say the vast majority of the
people i face i don't think they got
anything out of it from a skill
improvement perspective either
there isn't uh uh like with the whole
point of ranking systems yes it is sort
of skill-based matchmaking i know you're
not allowed to say that word because
you'll get a counselor
where i'm heading
yeah so we go
when you have established ranked floors
you have established skill brackets um
and there's an expectation and and
almost a predictability that comes with
those brackets that people are going to
play in a certain way and they're going
to have a certain amount of game
knowledge and this is going to be about
um you know like let's say let's say if
you're fabled to your 2100s if that was
a real thing that would be like average
i'd say most people should be able to
get to fabled they'll be able to hit
their shots they'll be able to rotate
they'll be able to know what an
objective is they'll be able to do maybe
have a couple of builds here or there
but you know like then you go to the
5500 let's say that's the top rank
you know i'm expecting and if it's done
correctly i'm expecting people with
encyclopedia knowledge to to try and
to try and take me down i'm i'm thinking
about hunters who are running top tree
night stalker which most people laugh at
but the fact you pair that with gemini's
jester or you pair it with uh graviton
forfeit which gives you advanced uh
class ability regeneration
you know you can use both of those
exotics for uh radar manipulation and
that throws people off and it can
completely break the rhythm of teams
because it blinds and it confuses people
you know i want to see
i want to see a playlist where
i don't have to go into
i i have to go into third fourth and
fifth gear to really
eek out of victory and in trials for me
and i know a lot of people like me and a
lot of people who are um you know
not super high skilled but even just
like above average they don't even have
to get out of second gear to get a win
and go for that completely understand
where you're coming from my question
then would be what he is alluding to
the the classic debate with uh
skill-based matchmaking well i was like
i
kind of that but also it sounds like for
it sounds like trials what they've made
now is a way to give people and a reason
to have incentive to go chase the loot
that people enjoyed looking at we've got
a new set of weapons in there and you've
also got a reason for people to play a
different game mode in elimination which
is going to give them some variety
is it like the elitist anything like
that
nomad did a video a long time ago about
what comp rework should be and that i
think when you go into die like i played
starcraft when i was
god knows how many years that's been uh
but even starcraft rank or rocket
lingering however you have the tiers
like if i log in and i'm in diamond 2 no
i probably wouldn't be in diamond let's
move that down to bronstead
but whatever like you're in you've got a
group of people around you
that if you jump in you're going to play
around there and then so and then that
way as nomad said it's like if i go in
i'm playing people around me and this
kind of goes back to the 70 70 matches i
played
when i jumped in and there was a three
stack i was like
crap most of the time just the way the
minute it is
the communication was like i think i got
him here it didn't catch the guy
flanking and again there's things that i
can kind of think of but also it was the
point where when i played like the solos
or the 2v1 and 2v1 when i got in those i
was like okay these two are going here
they're kind of occupied i can kind of
flank around catch them behind and
there's moments where i actually got to
try different things without like the
ultra elite knowing exactly the best
thing to do and i got a chance to i got
a chance to learn in those
i just didn't get to explain
experiment that much because those were
so rare in my card
because on those matches when it was
like solos or 2v1s and it wasn't and
every so often i did beat a three stack
but it wasn't that often when i would
play through those matches i was like
okay this
this is what i want to experience like
the whole way through for me at my level
and that would be a fun experience
there's some challenge there's some
sweat for me at my point but also
there's a point where it's like hey i
can kind of work on my shots because
i'm not seeing somebody slide through
midair and hit me in a snipe
and i was just like holy shut and i was
just like those moments i'm like dude
you are far beyond me but on the other
hand yeah but on the other side it's
like okay i'm trading i see somebody
flanking they're not doing it that fast
they don't make the best move i can
adjust those little things that i get a
chance to do
in a mid mid skill level match is what i
want more of and i think a ranked system
would be the best because trials is like
a cool way like again we can have the
kind of the debate is it elite whatever
but like a ranked trials and if you guys
got up to like platinum one like the
highest 5500 if you want to call
whatever that is
if you're at that level and you jump
into comp or ranked or whatever you want
to call it you know that's going to be
ultra sweaty but you know you've got
yourself there me if i'm going like
bronze three bronze two bronze one and i
can see progress as well that gives me
incentive to keep going but i'm there's
no way i should face a diamond one i
shouldn't even be in the same ballpark
that's why i was like trials is fun at
this point and i think it may serve as
you guys say almost a different purpose
which is fine but then comp now needs
the biggest rework
yep yeah so for like what i would like
so the original question was what is
what does it need to be considered
competitive and i think what it needs is
it needs a competitive environment like
if you think about what trials is as a
system now it's sort of like pulling a a
slot machine like like you don't know
the team you're gonna get set up against
and because there's not even a separate
playlist for full stacks it could be
solo queues it could be two people in
one it could be somebody of a completely
different skill set and and you don't
really see a lot of you you don't get to
peek behind the curtain and that was the
same problem with the old skill based
matchmaking system is people don't like
skill-based matchmaking when they don't
understand how they got into that and it
just seems like they're getting crushed
or crushing other people because
the reason people like ascendant and i
play trial or play
comp and i don't want to speak for a
senate but just the people i know who
play kong they don't play it because
they want to get to the lighthouse and
get the armor they play it because they
want to see iron sharp and iron we want
to become better by playing with other
players who are at our level or better
than us and we want to make other people
better by playing at the same level with
them yeah and if you think about what
comp is right now it's sort of like just
a
it's it's not a mountain top you're
climbing
with all these different layers it's
something where you're just sort of
completing laps right like you get to
legend and then you reset and then you
get to legend and reset but you're not
like setting yourself at okay i'm
diamond one and now i'm gonna play
against diamond one and i'm gonna try to
get to whatever it is that's above
diamond one right and and working your
way up that and i think if something
like that existed and it was transparent
how the skill was happening i had a
little icon next to my
tag that when i was in comp that showed
what skill level i was at then i would
then i i'm not as mad about skill-based
matchmaking because it's not just
matching me based on my playtime or my
kda or something arbitrary like that
that may not tell the full story it's
basing it off of the progress i've made
that season to get into that bracket and
then get matched with people in that
bracket so i just think it's a holistic
rework trials can continue to be what it
is right now it can continue to be the
fun as ascendant called it a a carnival
which i think is a super apt metaphor
it's a fun get in there play trials and
earn loot situation which i think
everybody is entitled to i'm okay with
matchmaking existing but trials had
previously been serving not well
recently but in the past it has served
the role of being end game content for
con but has it but it has but i just
don't have that now it didn't have what
you just described way long ago i'm
talking way long ago it didn't have
talking
trials never had that's why i said
you're asking you're acting as if that
was in place and then it got taken away
from you and thus we have the carnival
that is down trials never existed in
that format i'm trying to say it tried
to be that thing and it seemed like like
bungie was always trying to make it that
and they got off track and then rather
than going okay we're going to rework it
and make it the end content for crucible
they went the other direction and they
said okay it's just going to be iron
banner 2.0 it's just going to be our
replacement for you know a more social
playlist that's letting people in and my
whole point with this was i want trials
to be i i previously i don't know if
this is ever going to happen maybe now
comp is the future but i wanted there to
be an endgame
activity for crucible and i felt like
trials could be that if they reworked it
they went the other way and so of course
guys like me who want that are
disappointed like how can we not be like
there's no foreseeable future where we
have a endgame content for crucible and
that makes me that you know that's
disappointing i get when you're going to
an extent i guess for me
where you where you seemed a bit harder
on glory i felt
glory and comp attempted that better
than trials because i felt
glory at least had the visual
representation of this progression and
skill set of where you are to get to
this end game then there was the repeat
rinse repeat once you reset the the top
rank so to me trials was the epitome of
crapshoot prior i'm talking about pride
like i didn't know what skill i was
playing against i didn't know why i was
a bachelor i'm talking about d2 i'm not
talking about d1 you know about d2
i'm talking about d1 because in my in my
opinion d2 has never gotten trials right
and they've been trying to get back to
it but in d1 days it felt more like an
endgame activity to me i don't know if
there's something but even in d1
i understand but it was it was behind
the curtain but there was no visual
representation of it no there was there
was the card so the card and what step
you were under the card you were going
against people were only at that level
of the card and because the player base
was smaller
because the player base was smaller when
you get to rank or when you get to match
five six seven you sort of know who
you're going against and so right i'm
not saying it was perfect they've never
gotten it right in destiny has always
been just a complete crap shoot but
i wanted them to go in the direction and
and a lot of the stuff that they've said
over the years is we want that
competitive experience we want a
platform for the ultra sweaties and they
they seem to have gone in the opposite
direction and so of course guys like me
are disappointed but that doesn't mean i
think nobody should be able to play
trials and that i'm elitist and i want
like oh sir
i'm saying i'm even sure i'm even saying
last week
you said because matchmaking was
included you said they could have done
everything that they had every every
change was great except for memory you
said matchmaking was what threw this in
the bushes for you so again
with that involved if they partially
said
i said trials was unnecessary if they
had done all of the other changes except
for matchmaking
i think that they would have fixed 90 of
the problem
with with the fact that trials was
unrewarding that it was low not having a
high player base cross play alone why is
matchmaking getting all the credit for
fixing trials cross play dude if you
want to talk about increasing the player
base of course at least on a console
because i planned console there were so
many more people just because of cross
play so
um that that's my whole point but yeah
obviously i think matchmaking is like
that was sort of to me the signal of
like okay it there it's no longer even
trying to be
in game conference
like it's just they're just saying get
in there hop in casually one single solo
queue and that sort of thing and some
solo queuers went flawless i mean you
saw your king david he was said he was
in a two stack and you went flawless to
me that's like and then guys like me
like we're not even trying like i i
literally went flawless my first card
with uh dj oros and and men's and those
guys right you shout out to dj
you know [ __ ]
contemplating on this a lot yeah
[Laughter]
so the matchmaking point is definitely
an interesting one and we can we can
debate
um the merits of whether or not
matchmaking is the sole reason why
trials is or isn't competitive but on a
more fundamental level we have to keep
our expectations in check because
this
game is not ever going to reach the
level of competitiveness that we like to
compare to holistically
because
because because
i've said that too many times yeah
so because of peers appear so
you know whatever whatever bungie does
with respect to matchmaking i feel like
is is very much just trying to solve
that issue well and and it's it's a
miracle it works as well as it does
sometimes um though i don't think any of
us individually privately publicly
whatever can ever go one week without
having a terribly laggy match so the
system has limitations and if they
really wanted to make a truly
competitive game they pour everything
over to dedicate servers they have ptrs
where they can test rule sets they can
test new maps
there needs to be there needs to be the
culture to support it too and i'm not
talking about the uh the the 15 year
olds on twitter who who create raw sets
and
harass content creators um i'm talking
about like generally from the ground up
like something that's endorsed by an
external organization or bungie sets up
an external organization to handle
competitive create tournaments create
like to update their tos so that they
can have
um more than ten thousand dollars as
prize money because right now
everybody's playing for like twenty
dollars or seven 711 gift cards which is
adorable
but it's um like like ultimately trying
to trying to make a mountain of a mole
hill is is
personally not in my best interest i try
not to i try not to think too much about
what it could be because the bones
aren't there right now and until they
actually make an effort to make the
bones more solid
um
it's a bit of a point isn't it yeah
that's all i was trying to say i think i
think for me
you know
i never
i got to the point with bungie just with
the whole separation between pvp and pve
the non-separation sometimes you know
when it comes to balancing and sandbox
it's just a game that in my opinion is
they have proven it's just too difficult
to balance right so on that fundamental
core level of weapon sandbox i never
looked at this game as the ultimate
competitive like halo i look at like an
arena shooter balanced map placement map
control that's the epitome of pvp
balance and you can tweak it and work at
that sandbox better but destiny just has
so many extra variables and then and
then abilities let's be real like
we want to speak to that actually yeah
please certainly
no please um i know i was writing on the
the scrim scene just now because it's
it's they
it's easy um but i do want to give them
credit actually because some of the rule
sets they do come up with they they
generally like to sit down and they they
look at the stuff and they say okay this
is really really powerful we're gonna
omit that and this is really really easy
to proc so we're gonna admit that we're
gonna we're gonna ban this we're gonna
ban that and you look at these rule sets
and and they look ridiculous on on the
face of things they look like
no fun allowed is is the best way to
describe it but then you sit down you
actually play with them and you get a
glimpse of what might be
which is the most tragic thing you you
really
they really do think about them and they
do think about how it all plays together
and yes sometimes it gets a bit samey
everybody runs hand cannon shotgun
anyways um
it's it's it's a wonderful look at what
would happen to the crucible if gun play
and gun play only was allowed to shine
right and yeah i mean literally just
reiterating what i wanted to say too
which is that it's just it's just the
nature of the game and the ability spam
and supers jessie just has way too many
variables so for me i understand travis
is concerned and wanting it to be
the pinnacle of pv and that's something
still to for them i know they as a
studio i know they want to aspire for
that i know they still want that of
course you know but at the end of the
day i just i think it comes down to
the survival of the game
versus the vision of the game right and
that's that conflict at the end of the
day that's the problem and they looked
at it they tried
the sweats were in there and everything
that they tried just wasn't working then
on top of it we didn't talk obviously
the anti-cheat which was another can of
worms besides the dedicated like a
dedicated service and all sort of stuff
so the way i look at it yeah they're
doing the best they can and i trust me i
i know me and travis have a little thing
but i know where he's coming from i know
he what he's saying to his core
is right in the face that this is not
the pvp
hardcore i'm going to learn i'm going to
get better at the highest level and i've
already you know what's the word you
just say like okay forget it you know
it's never going to be that currently in
the stage of acceptance you know
so i've said like a million times on the
show that like i don't think but destiny
will ever be balanced and i mean that
for pve and people but that said pvp is
is so vital to destiny because it has
always kept the game alive when created
i'm with you and
the group that has kept it alive most
are the hardcore sweaty people who like
to play this game and try to make a
competitive game out of it so i don't
think it's impossible to make a
mode that at least puts people in
brackets that season for and gives them
an aspirational kind of grind to move up
and down and they don't even have to
lock
specific gear behind that they can give
me a title or give me a glow or give me
a weapon that's a certain color so that
when i rock it people are like oh he was
in the diamond group
there's you know there's lots of
different uh options that don't have to
be oh i'm elitist and i want loot that
nobody else can get that's not my play
at all i just think that they could do a
lot better than they're doing in terms
of comp it doesn't have to be a perfect
it's never going to be halo i don't want
it to be halo i already have halo and
i'm very excited to be playing in a
couple months but uh i you know i i just
uh i just think that they could be doing
a lot better and i think it would help
the health of the game if they created
something that like that because it
would reward the people who keep the
game alive when destiny doesn't have pve
content which let's be honest that's
like most of the time oh yes
oh yeah not having enough content and
having to rely on an old crap so i think
uh i i just i you know of course i'm
disappointed but like am i mad that that
they had record numbers and trials this
weekend like no i was thought she was i
know she was tearing up the stat sheets
i was just messing with you i know i
know i had a big smile on my face i was
like this is awesome i love that people
are playing pvp now i'm gonna get into
the playlist and make them wish they
hadn't
and that is uh that's how i do it so
respect last place so that we could be
in the middle here um what about like
you making fantastic points as far as um
that distinction on the on the highest
level like do like let's say the next
iteration would be like that
i don't see like a comp ranking system
like we talk about this diamond and
stuff like that and then or at least
separate the playlists for trials i
think that has to happen i don't think
we can have one
i think we have to have freelance and
then we have the free stacks now that's
where i'm with you
the the biggest flaw for me was the like
i said i this is why i'm like damn they
really do need the freelance because
i really felt and i know shout out to
people who did go go solo you know you
know
i just watched them
reaction when you said that
it's been an interesting one so go first
yeah no no no it just it's just i i've
seen a few people say they've gone
flawless in this new system just
matchmaking whatever amazing which is
amazing right what i did solo and i'm
i'm going to be honest i got slapped it
was so hard because i was playing
against full stacks i was just like dude
these guys aren't communicating
and i felt at that once i got to five to
seven that's what me and travis are the
complete agreement i just felt it was
completely unfair because it's a
difference when i'm playing with other
people in the same situation as me who
are also freelancing and not team but
the minute i seen two people with a clan
tag the same on the opposition i pretty
much knew it was a wrap because those
guys have better communication and we're
going to be dominant so that's where i
do agree with the separation that at
some point with this trials labs i would
love that freelance so this way i know
everyone is in the same boat as i am and
it is you know it's it's not going to be
oh yeah they had the two stacked to
three step but i'm sorry no matt you was
going to continue no no no no go ahead
no i'm fine that was my point
i completely forgot oh no
like for me that's
i watched the debate over the weekend
everybody's like don't jump the gun the
population is big and that was one of
the things that i saw a lot of people
talking about with regards to
because as you said i played 70 matches
my win rate was about 21
it was pretty rough because i did two
cards i did each one to seven wins i did
first ferocity because the three turned
into four got me my wins faster then i
switched it over to wealth so i got more
ranking points to level up that way seem
to have some benefit
um and going through that
as i said the times when i matched with
mixes for me felt good but there was
like a slew when i was at like three or
four wins on my second card three sec
three stack three stack three stack
three stack three stack and i'm like
this yeah hurts
and those those are the moments when i'm
like
if everybody was freelance or everybody
was like your three stacks
that would balance things out but then
you have the division you have you think
now versus you think
five months from now the end of season
of the loss when the population gets
smaller and then people are wondering
okay how
how divided are the playlists gonna be
then how many people are still gonna be
playing what is the matchmaking gonna
look like console
as you have both xboxes all the
playstations you have all of those and
stadia the those five people
all of that grouped in together for
i think the console pool actually could
probably manage split
because it is so big
when you go to pc
you already have the certain number of
people in there then you have like
somewhat sweaty mouse and keyboard ultra
sweats in there the threes are gonna be
like what in that lake they're gonna
walk into you know basically the okay
corral and try and dodge all the crazy
bullets and then the freelance that may
incentivize more people to go into
freelance depending on it so there's
this whole debate over like splitting
the playlist there's like console i
think could manage and if they tried it
there
to see i can understand pc being a
smaller pool but i was like there are
times when i was in there like i could
just have a freelance playlist i could
at least enjoy my time whether i win or
lose at least i know i'm like
you're gonna have you're gonna play
against like one person on like a solo
stack that's like yeah that one dude
carried their whole team and i was in
the same boat like i did well on one and
i was like i had like i had a 9.0 in one
match and i was like holy crap but on
the other side i also had like 0.5 and a
dude carried my butt through that win so
i was like you have those mixes but if
it's threes against a mix it is rough
but also people are like we just got the
population to a good place everybody's
scared to say if you divide it is that
gonna hurt it and i just don't know and
that's why i was like i don't know the
right answer there and that's the
biggest one is i don't know the numbers
i don't know how much we got we saw crap
ton you know from destiny trials report
the number of players that cued
i would just i would be curious
to see and even i guess like a mix for
me would be like every third weekend
every second weekend every fourth
weekend you get a freelance playlist
that's a guaranteed in rotation so you
don't split them all the time
but that solo player still has an
opportunity you know
not too far away that they can go play
flawless because if they're worried
about the pop and they could like
balance it and see like hey this weekend
we've got it this week and we don't and
kind of see what the numbers are like
just wondering if that would even work
since we don't know yet
it might work
as long as it's telegraphed and marketed
ahead of time like this revamp was like
say hey this is solos playlist is coming
out just like you know even if it's a 12
mission the the the point is you need to
make people aware about it you need to
encourage people to actually try it out
and whether you do that with better loot
or you do that with a different take on
the game mode whatever
i think
wondering if the population withhold
will hold is a valid concern yeah but
it's also we have to remember we are
completely in uncharted territory right
now like we've never had this many
players in trials we've never had this
many matches and trials six month season
in
the probably the most stacked holiday
season coming up that i can even
remember
um yeah populations can take a hit and
probably as soon as like november but
you know like
it's it really is a case of crossing
that bridge when we get to it and then
making the right
making the right decision based on the
data available and but crucially also
having an open and frank conversation
about it too
leaving people in the dark and leaving
the game mode to suffer
that will be way worse than any decision
made about solo freelance being made
permanent or not
agree yeah
yeah i'm not really sure on that one a
part of me thinks maybe the purpose of
keeping the solo and duo players in the
main playlist is because they're not
supposed to be going flawless really i
mean maybe you'll have a fluke once or
twice but for the most part if you're
playing there you're just trying to get
your card went glutes and you know grind
your loot and that sort of stuff and and
i i appreciate that the problem is that
it means that players like me if the
player base remains as high as it is uh
are are basically just never going to
get to play trials against other people
who are in in squads which maybe that's
not the purpose of trials anymore i'm
not really sure it is totally uncharted
territory but uh yeah i think um it
could work but i don't really have um
i'm not really sure yeah i mean we'll
just we'll have to wait and see but it's
clear they're sort of
responding quickly i mean we saw new
tweaks in the 12 which maybe we should
get into you know like that's yeah where
i'm going good transition yeah yeah good
choices yeah let's let's let's do that
but yeah i'm not sure there uh they have
an answer yet i think they're probably
gonna wait a couple more weekends and
see what happens to the player counts
before they they make a decision like
that which i think is probably smart
yeah i agree with drive i think it it's
it's bungie seems to to work wait on the
analytics and the data before they move
the vibe i get from them is and we'll
get into it is uh this is like a stage
process and i think for them the initial
goal was population that it was just too
low no one's playing it we have to do
something the change is kick created
strongly towards that now it's a matter
of okay we gotta address these other
issues the tweaks and i'll let you go
because it's a perfect transition like
trying to say yeah no i mean the twab is
one of the biggest things they mention
are the upcoming changes and there's
even a tweet that some couple definitely
points of contention i'll be curious um
tomorrow there will be a few changes
going live for the second week of trials
of osiris 4 season of the lust
they're not satisfied with matchmaking
experience for players after seven wins
and i didn't notice that when i sat at
seven wins i was just getting stopped
constantly hence why i actually reset my
card to go try that was very frequent uh
that area of matchmaking has a
significantly higher rate of 50 games
than we would like
sounds about right so we are enabling a
flawless matchmaking pool
however we want to make sure that there
are enough flawless players to maintain
good matchmaking times so we're waiting
until friday afternoon to turn this on
and we will be watching player reactions
and matchmaking analytics all weekend to
make sure it's behaving
properly now fallout tweeted to cosmo
about this and he actually got a reply
because fallout asked yo
pretty sure i know the answer but just
double checking the flawless matchmaking
are the flawless matchmaking are you
still in that new flawless pool even
after you reset your card or are you in
that pool when your card is at 7-0
flawless and cosmo replied once you go
flawless for the week you start by
trying to match with other flawless
folks it may eventually resort to not to
matching against non-flawless but it
resets every weekend so if you get a
flawless ticket
at any point in the weekend you are now
considered flawless
you know in that 7-0 matchmaking it
sounds like so before i go any farther
because that literally happened not that
long ago i wanted to get kind of
everybody's thoughts especially the two
more hardcore who may get stuck in the
flawless at that point
i want to
my initial thought to this was that
the longer the weekend goes on the
easier it's going to be for everyone to
go flawless because all the people who
already flawless are going to be in a
separate matchmaking playlist and so i
it's not i like that there's a way for
flawless people to play against other
flawless i think that's great but it
makes me wonder like is everyone gonna
be in that playlist by the end because
then you're only playing against people
who haven't gone flawless yet and it
just it i i haven't seen it in action
yet so i i have no idea but that was my
first thought is dang so if you want to
go flawless just wait till monday
morning hop on with your friends and
only end up in a crew of people who
aren't good enough to have gone flawless
by monday yet like that's just that
seems crazy to me now you're gonna start
ranking you got a friday flawless that's
hard saturday flawless is like medium
sunday flawless a little casual yeah and
then like monday flawless like you just
told us everybody come on in yeah
i don't know
the the real the real time is tuesday
morning before yes
that's just that's that's a cream right
there yeah i i think like because
sometimes like this weekend for example
i didn't even get to play until monday
because i was super busy with reviews
over the weekend so like i'm worried
that like i'll have missed the boat like
my my trials experience is basically
gonna be like all right you just smash
these children in the face and then you
can start playing with your boys i just
don't feel like that's a good opening to
my child's weekend so you don't want to
go pull up on the playground and start
challenging
dude
you and me
monday night we got the monday night
my view on this is
it's it's it's tricky i i i'm i'm very
i'm very hesitant to give reactions to
things we haven't seen yet um but on the
face of it
this is gonna suck for people who like
to help people to ride to the lighthouse
that's gonna absolutely suck carries are
not going to happen
or they're going to happen but they're
going to be harder for a lot of people
it is interesting that you said that
like what travis said it's like
eventually
if the population holds and the people
keep playing and they they are
encouraged to keep playing because they
know the sweaty people won't be in their
playlist
everybody will go flawless
and
then what happens there is they'll get
their flawless and be like okay i'm just
gonna be matching with like two point
threes and three point threes and four
point threes i'm out
so you'll see the increase of
so what i'm predicting is you might
actually see a net increase or or rather
the same amount of people going flawless
if the population holds
but
way less matches played
so when you see the trials report
statistics at the end of uh on on monday
or tuesday
i i think we're gonna see
maybe uh
a third reduction in matches because you
can see people playing less you're going
to have the average players and above
average players they might stick around
they might give it a go they might like
you know if you have a chance for an
adapt show your is the end of the match
or a depth flawless weapon um you know
facing off against another 7-0 team
another flawless team is
well it's it's earned right you did that
once you should do it again so
idealistically makes perfect sense
in reality
not sure about this i think it'll kill
the replayability for a lot of players
sweaty regardless
before you go cog one more thing i
realized that uh i think it might be a
problem
um
people who are trying to grind for god
rolls on weapons or armor or what have
you yeah i could see them intentionally
throwing cards so that they can stay in
the non-flawless lap matchmaking lists
for the week and then they're just
getting to six wins racing matches or
just resetting their cards and then just
uh doing that over and over again to
grind for stuff so just like we had when
the initial trials relaunch where people
were losing after the third match or
resetting their cards so that they could
just crush the easy matches i can see
that happening because of the way the
loot game works now so like i said
they're like matchmaking and this whole
this whole system it's it's going to
introduce new complexities that we
haven't thought of yet and i think
that's possibly one of them
i see no i'm just like i'm literally
reading the feedback from twitter as i'm
going through because it's coming here
so grenada jake
uh wait so even if i reset my card after
going flawless i'm going to match
flawless teams the rest of the weekend
that will make helping people flawless
kind of tough as you guys stated
couldn't i just avoid this by resetting
my card at six wins every time and
stopping myself from going flawless
so that's one
um it is confirmed it's a character or
account based it is account based
so it's even corroded
uh they said they will be watching both
analytics and feedback and trying to
balance fast matches with good matches
across the player base it's definitely
not set in stone um
those are the big three i'm trying to
see if cosmo replied anything but those
were a couple of big ones uh and then
fallout's reply was just dot dot dot oh
so i mean you can kind of read yeah you
can read his thoughts on that one um but
yeah it's like carries is going to be
tough but also in turn it's like are
they
are they trying actually that's the so
that's the solution to carries though
isn't it like if you're carrying someone
nomad you can just get to six wins and
reset your card without the person
you're carrying get the seventh lens
yeah 100 do that and then and then you
go flawless at the end of the week like
on monday you just you go uh and make uh
cog and he cry on monday morning
yeah we'll go and be like who's this guy
this guy's not supposed to be here
yeah
no it's it's it's really strange like i
i understand that it will
but this is this is the thing i don't
understand is
they said that the reason for doing this
is that they found that most matches at
seven were resulting in five o's right
yes or or higher than than expected
percentage and that was actually my
experience i can confirm that when i was
doing my helps and i was carrying people
on my server and in my
clan one of us would actually just do
you have a flawless card and usually be
me or my my other carry partner and say
yeah okay we're gonna cue in on your
lead so we queued in four flawless games
when other people were at zero and we
had easier matches the whole way through
so there was something broken there was
a hundred percent something that needed
to be fixed but i'm not really sure
that
locking flawless people behind flawless
tickets only is the right way to go
especially given that 30 of the
population went flawless right yeah that
doesn't seem like a good solution to me
but then again it's one weekend and they
said they might change it so let's give
it a go let's
i i'm not optimistic about it i don't
think really anybody is when you think
about it for more than two seconds um
but it doesn't solve the problem it
doesn't solve the problem yeah i was
like
yeah go ahead no i was just gonna say i
think this comes back to what i was
basically arguing for last week is
a lot of us who listen to podcasts watch
videos who are deep enough into this
game to be kind of in depth in it
whether it's skill or otherwise are
still probably that like 20 30 percent
of people who are
not what bungie is probably trying to
cater half of these decisions towards
like you have a very solo
casual
audience who doesn't even like look at
youtube videos who just logs in to do
some strikes and they're looking at this
and saying hey we still have a vast
chunk of our player base
who might be able to engage on tuesday
but if we can get them to engage a
little bit more on a weekend they're
gonna have a player base that sticks
around more frequently maybe they go
after some ornaments maybe they spend
more than they ever restore it's still
that business side of things that i
think for them
they're trying to say
yeah there's an angry minority but the
vast majority is somewhat some of these
decisions are for and this feels like
one of those is all i'm saying it feels
like it leans into
a lot of the people that we don't
typically think about because we're not
those people right
it gives the it gives that angry
minority a lot of chances to just like
game the system and
you know what i'm saying like yeah
you're not wrong
and yeah definitely i mean definitely
valid concerns i'm not gonna sit there
and say that these concerns are not
valid i just think like nomad said one
week let's see what happens first that's
the first thing second i think it's one
of those situations kind of like what
you say when you look at the whole you
look at the percentage and then how do
we now address the flawless run right
how do we address that so that there's
no exploitation there but to me it's a
bigger issue
than all of that and to me my concern is
actually
that with this system and the initial
success of the system this is going to
put a lot of pressure on them to now
have
solid rewards that match it because this
first week was reed's regret and granted
it was worth doing it it's a
stasis linear fusion it's the season of
diffusion linear fusion right now we all
got that particle deconstruction mod or
whatever it's called and that is a high
reward something to chase for right the
pressure to me is on the loo in the
reward team for people to go in because
at the end of the day we could farm and
people could farm but once the elite get
what they want for the most part unless
they're doing carries yes
they're going to be out and the majority
is going to still serve that majority
who is more casual will pop in here and
there that gets to the season late to me
it comes down to the reward teams now as
well and them stepping up so that each
week trials is introduced
there are new weapons new things and
that's something i've always had to boot
on their neck on even with iron banner
you know thank god we got the the the
peace bond and the stasis thing you know
i'm saying because that made me okay i
got to get an iron banner but other than
that
the pvp rewards in comparison to the pve
there's always been a negative disparity
and i want to see even exotics i want to
see stuff like how we had we traveled to
about the pinnacle days right there
needs to be reason and incentive to
properly get into pvp to get those
weapons and armors or whatever that you
can't get elsewhere and that's the one
that i'm fear-mongering i'm like once
you have yet to prove to me
that you guys are going to be consistent
because the minute we did have something
goodbye mountaintop goodbye recluse
goodbye
all right i got my babies neutered you
know what i'm saying so that that's all
about my making sure but i understand
where everyone's going that's a real
concern because as other people say is
if it's
if you get to the point where now as you
guys say by monday
50 60 of the population has gone
flawless
if you do this for six or seven weeks
potentially depending on how drops are
going
you're gonna have at least one of
potentially every adept weapon now as an
even average player possibly if you play
on that like tuesday morning you might
get the hook up
but like then is that the point like how
long does that carrot on the stick stick
out there if you like i've done the
sweaty trials it's fun for a little bit
gives me a little bit of a reward
how long will that last and again what
is that going to do the population but
these are all tough things because
they're trying to get people into the
playlist period to get them to start but
then how long do they stay and this is a
six month season so it's going to be an
abnormal one anyway but when you turn
around and say like hey once you've got
the weapon are they going to go back in
there have you given them enough of a
reason is it fun enough experience is it
something that they can get something
out of or have they got all they need
and they're out and that's one thing i
think only time is going to tell but as
you said if they don't keep making new
armor new weapons new cosmetics new
changes to these things on a consistent
basis which we typically have not seen
that is setting us up for failure at
some point yeah especially yeah
yeah
agreed okay
step two of the twelve are we about to
okay cool no i was like we're still uh
we're still talking about crucible uh
yep sure
because i just you know i want to make
sure we get in our long running segment
before oh yeah no yeah we haven't even
got to that yet
don't you worry things went out of order
from my plan but we'll get there i got
you i'm going to get up at everything
you just beat me up okay amazing
so they said they're also not happy with
the experience of players who have a bad
streak of getting repeatedly thrashed
5-0
so we are enabling some matchmaking help
if someone runs into several blowout
matches this temporary help mechanic
clears up once they start winning again
so don't think someone will cheese a
flawless by tanking for a few games and
then have a weekend of smooth sailing
thoughts
yes that's me yeah like i i was i was on
the run man i was like yo i might be
able to do it 5-0 solo matchmaking i
just i just figured out a uh a new rule
for you and ebontus's uh
so here's what you do you log in on
friday and you get five losses
then you wait till that monday morning
that's wednesday morning i'm done with
you
you're gonna be like here's that
flawless on your silver letter enjoy
i have done it
that's the strat right there that's
distracting so get those
what's going to be more valuable is
there a video or how to cheat the system
at trials
[Laughter]
that was my thing because
there was there were a couple of moments
where i'm like yo i'm doing good every
match made team i'm carrying
i'm feeling good i might be able to
shout the forte he he actually did it
but
every time i got to five wins bro
i would always see that double clan name
on the other side that three stack on
the other side and i'm not one to yell
at my blueberries but damn it they were
failing me badly bro i'm like guys what
are you doing stop looking where are you
going why did nobody had my butt over
here on the other like i'm looking here
there's two of you behind me what are
you doing bro and i'm not even that
skilled yeah that's when i became travis
and i was like if you damn guys i could
communicate with you and you can tell
you stop getting pinched stop getting
picked and i said you know what the
advantage of of the match made squad
because that is how it should go that we
should get stopped right but if it's in
a matchmaking playlist in my opinion
that's where the freelance gotta come
back in but we gotta see i just i just i
just struggle with the algorithm
and unless the population is still not
big enough right i just struggle with
the algorithm still putting me up
against two stacks and three stacks i
just don't know how
the the matchmaking algorithm works dude
it's just very interesting but i
definitely felt it bro cause it it took
away chances for me to attempt it so i
don't know what you guys thought i think
it prioritizes uh how many wins you have
on your car yeah probably how many uh
how many people you have in your fire
team and so
yeah clearly the the playlists are big
but it's still a minority of players in
destiny so yeah
yeah yep yep what do you guys think no
matter what you think any thoughts about
the whole 5-0 matchmaking
you got to protect the average player
you have to make sure that their
experience isn't a negative one
from what i've seen
i feel like
the the
for for a lot of people who are getting
thrash for a lot of people who are
struggling in the playlist
you know for them at least there was
loot
yeah at least there was that was the
that was from what made it all better is
the round wins the reputation all that
that will get old
they'll get their loot they'll get their
roles that they want and they'll be
happy with that and then
like we said before it's like is the
core experience fun enough to keep
playing and if the core experience for
them is getting thrash 5-0 you got to
address that and i think they're right
to address it i'm not
sure
if
artificially taking people out of a pool
and putting them into another artificial
pool within the same pool
is the solution
i'm not sure if it's going to be
implemented well
and i'm not sure if it's going to be
implemented in such a way that the
grades match quality and and and
puts people from across the world
together just because they're they're
you know they're zero and five
so
there's a lot of unknowns here there's a
lot of question marks but
you know the fact that they're trying
this and the fact that they're
even trying to
address that even messing with the
match-making algorithm in ways we've
never seen before you have never seen
this yeah that's that's interesting to
me that
i think somebody who's running the show
is very sharp and very switched on
because
that's an experiment i've never seen
before and just to jump it that's what's
giving me hope
because as a neglected
pvp lover
to see that level of transparency and
quick
transparency gives me hope that they are
paying attention because as travis me we
know bro we don't get no love on this
side our community will get no love bro
it's like the pvp mains we're dying out
here and to see them even talk about it
i'm like oh daddy's spending time with
me today
if i can give a if i can give a bungee
please for this thing
i'm fine
i'm fine with bungie doing this rule
where if you lose five times you get
added to a separate playlist but
after trials is over on tuesday at reset
bungie must release a full
unabridged list of all the gamer tags
that were in that playlist
if they ever appeared and
there's a separate sub list on that of
people who ended the weekend in that
playlist people who stayed there right
i want that to be published then it'll
be okay oh don't you sound like
you want public shaming right there and
then the top of that list tiger travis
he lost those five matches on friday and
he forgot to log in on tuesday morning
he got stuck in a review and man we're
just yeah first one in travis got in at
1205.
everybody else followed restaurant
the first team to enter that playlist i
should get uh one of those belts that
the raid team would get
i said i think
don't you get suspenders this isn't
anything to brag about you get like this
yeah the carry the carry suspenders that
you need
i'm done classic
uh no but i i'm all seriousness i'm fine
with this i don't think it really
bothers anybody i i think it will be
important that they
not let this uh
like they said they they they say don't
worry they'll they'll get out of this
playlist once they get a few wins that
needs to happen but uh we'll see how it
affects we'll shout out those yeah i
don't really care about this to be clear
uh one more thing they are adding this
weekend is quitter penalties which is
good can't tell you how many people got
a couple rounds in you'd see somebody
drop out they're like it's a three stack
i already lost two let me get out of
here then you completely screw your
entire rest of them there's no incentive
not to they're just going to go find
another match
yeah i i hated playing against uh
through e2s it's yeah too yeah it's soft
girl
no matter what you it didn't happen to
me but i faced teams that we stomped
them first three rounds yeah and then
they one of their guys or that person
they left and i'm like that's messed up
don't do those two dudes like that
on the flip side the lots of emo parties
and trials
lots of high fives with the enemy teams
lots of uh yeah the aeroplane emote but
like bro i got a lot of ggs post match
people were happy to play but yeah we
got to fix they got a serious penalty
guys that do it not no trials you can't
do that going back to the question what
would make it competitive
there we go that's an argument that's
another one yeah
so next week uh so this friday is this
week that we're talking about the
following week which will be 23rd 24th i
guess math-wise uh in addition to our
first trials labs spoiler alert it is a
capture zone trials
this will be actually a different
mechanic to trials we will be disabling
the special ammo replenishment on revive
i didn't know it did that or i wasn't
paying attention but i didn't know on
revive you get your special ammo back is
that yeah i'm just apparently that
unaware
yeah you get your special armor back
not that you
you don't want to throw obviously just
so you get a bit more special ammo
that's silly you put your team uh a man
down but like yeah that's that was the
thinking i'm surprised it wasn't it is a
thing yeah like that seems like
something yeah um so it'll be disabling
uh especially replenishment on revive
you still get special ammo if you kill
someone or when you start the next round
that seems practical i didn't know the
other one was there they said they're
also disabling the matchmaking counter
on the trials of osiris lobby you won't
be able to tell how many players have
joined but will be told when they joined
uh we also fixed an issue preventing you
from being able to masterwork uh
messenger weapons from saint 14's the
rank awards apparently you couldn't
master work the couple that they showed
if you went through the ranks um i saw a
cool guy tweet about this probably first
he may have not been the first but the
first one that came into my thread yeah
about like if they saw five to six okay
then they were good because they're like
okay we got two waiting on one more as
opposed to just switching in mm-hmm so
between the leaving penalties and then
also the fact that you can't see the
counter people can't hunt down the solos
or the two or the singles as a three
stack which it's already random enough
for us solos you three shouldn't get
another advantage to be like oh look
here's a good one like that
that was it random i i'm i'm not
convinced it was as random as you think
he i think the reason you got matched up
against so many people is because uh the
three stacks were hunting for solo
queuers and duo viewers yeah so that'll
be coming so that'll be next week
yeah so it's like and again as you said
cog like these are fast
this week we've got this many changes
coming in to check on matchmaking see
what the flawless does that'll be a work
in progress probably next week now i've
got matchmaking the penalties come in
you've got the lobby that you can't see
the special ammo they're actively
watching trials on a weekly basis to
really try and give this some
nourishment which is you guys have said
it's been
what two years since we've had a map and
all this renewed focus like it's been so
long
to see this much focus on it it's really
weird to see this much focus on it with
no like seasonal content directed toward
it no new maps no new game modes it's
like wow they're really all in for
you know how much they're not giving us
anything they're they're sure giving us
a lot of attention
absolutely that's exciting though
i great completely great travis because
it's like at the end of the day and this
is where i'm i'll die on my soul with
travis on this one is that
you know i know about those households
days and i remember you know it was dark
out here there was no raid that season
and that's when trials of osiris debuted
and i don't care what anyone say like
trials had destiny on its back pvp had
its or on its back and to see that
renewed focus towards it goes to show
you that if you put the time and
resources and dedication
you can keep this game alive with a
pillar that you've already proven you've
done it before in d1 right so now to see
them with this level of agility and
transparency this is what i want to
continue to see because what trials is
good with pvp is good look what this
game does look what look at the
engagement you get it should be a stark
reminder to them yeah we need this is a
core pillar of the experience not an
additive experience this is core and
keep on man and i love it this is great
to see keep on with it man we gotta get
traffic
yeah i've always thought that they
should like
since they have these long seasons and
they only use like six weeks of it for
the pve content i've always thought why
don't they do the second half of the
season where nothing's happening why
don't they make that the pvp focus stuff
and do iron banner and trials and the
new map releases and all that stuff then
in those gaps where we have nothing and
people are looking for ways to extend
their destiny playtime anyway and it's
kind of weird the timing of this too
because the pve story still isn't done
it's actually kind of at its climax and
they're doing all this so yeah i'm
interested to see if they continue to do
this like long into the season because
we've got a long season ahead of us and
this is not the time i expected them to
be focusing on
as much as they are but it's uh
refreshing for sure
i agree i imagine they're gonna have
some things in the 30th anniversary that
they haven't really released yet but
when you consider that they made some
promises some pretty overt promises
through that massive twitter thread and
then
um also in in some of the showcase notes
as well
that they wanna they they really want to
make
the goal is to be consistent right and
in order to to be consistent you have to
have the structures and the processes in
place in your organization to
to to build upon because consistency is
just
a series of
really really well functioning parts and
and all producing a tangible outcome
reliably and
when you consider what we've just come
from months and months and months and
months the years of silence
snippets a line or two in in a
twab talk about it a one a one-off
podcast which was great by the way um
with firing range and then like the the
the odd
like featurette in a balancing pass and
then some comments on reddit like these
aren't
this isn't feedback this isn't this
isn't
content this isn't communication this is
these are literally crumbs
you know
so
what they're doing here it we are
talking about the star contrast we are
talking about like yeah they're
listening they're going all in but for
me i think this is just like the
necessary groundwork that they need to
do
if they want to set out the goals that
they could very publicly declare saying
hey we want to be consistent well you
got to be consistent communicators you
have to learn how to do that you have to
be okay with changing things on the fly
and being okay with getting the the
ridiculously harsh feedback that pvp
players are not afraid to give because i
don't think there is a single more
um
virulently uh passionate
section of the fan base aside from pvp
and and part of it is an exact part of
it is passionate i don't know call it
what you want but you have to be okay
with with listening to that side of the
community and then acting upon what they
suggest which you don't have to listen
to them completely but you know assess
what they say and then weigh that
against your design priorities and then
go for that and go from there so
what they're doing right now to me it's
it's really really good
but it's also if they didn't do this i'd
be really really concerned about that
yeah me and travis said it week after
week we're like yo do they even care
about it is it is have the resources
going to the new ip matter you know has
is pvp something they even want to
continue i mean we've had deep
discussions because like you said
beautifully that no man like
it was it was bursting breadcrumbs there
were seasons upon season at some point
right that there were nothing there was
literally no mention of pvp
and that was very concerning so to me to
see this level
shows that there is a recommitment we
know that they're still um hiring
they're still doing things you know
obviously we know this the work's not
done we got we need maps we need you
know the raw system
we're not there but what i like is let's
build and fix the foundation of the
house that's how i look at this this is
house foundation stuff right once we get
the house right then we can expand and
get the greater goods and now i have
confidence that they care about me they
care about us daddy's talking to us
again i was feeling the way we were he
was getting all the love he every every
twab is all about e and his wants and
his armor and all this and paul corcock
and trash sitting there suffering like
neglected children and finally daddy's
home to play with us
daddy came up with a goofy second
time i was gonna say somebody's gonna
read into this podcast and be like uh
cog how was how's how's childhood you
okay how's your childhood was he okay
this is probably the second time cog and
i are experiencing childhood or
fatherhood neglect
[Music]
i'll be back any day now
that's what he told us last time
that's that's what he told us last time
he said he's going to be back
and he's going with a renewed focus
right
yes
no matt i'll have you know i'll have you
know cog and e know me as a pvp main who
has very uh soft takes i don't take
really hard-line positions
that is a perfect time to take us into
our long running segment i'm gonna pass
it over to travis sir the floor is yours
all right ascendant nomad welcome uh i
i'm glad i get to talk to you because i
i saw your episode with uh ibontas and
cog before i was a regular on the show
and and i thought you had some pretty
great insights we have a long-running
segment on the show and long-running
meaning that this is like the third time
we've done it
um
and it's called it's a segment called
let's help ebontis and the purpose of
the segment
is
we bring pvp mains onto the show and i
have them give us their top tip for a
player who has a 0.43
kba ratio and crucible
really really would like to improve what
are your top tips so on the show i think
previously i have mentioned or somebody
else has mentioned the two second rule
which i think is really crucial i know
you did a video recently where you did
the two-sixth rule it was a something or
40-60 rule that was not mean uh
that or somebody else did that um so
basically whatever your
whatever your top tip is for somebody
who's trying to finally cross that
threshold to being serious and starting
to climb the the mountain that is
crucible so that that's the segment and
uh if you want to take a moment to think
of it we can uh we can really just like
flame ibontis in the chat while you what
you what you uh compose your thoughts
sure um i do want to shout out the the
creator for the 40-second rule uh his
name is shadow destiny and i think you
guys should have him on he's he's really
well spoken
um
his his rule for those of you who don't
know it's basically a positioning rule
um and basically
40 of your screen whether you're peaking
from the left or the right of your
screen uh outside of code 40
should be of your screen should be
occupied by a piece of cover now there's
there's a lot more to it there's a lot
more intricacies to it you obviously
rules are there to be broken for certain
situations but that's the crux of it and
you should go check out that video
because it is very very very very very
good
but to help ubontis i think we need to
go to something much more rudimentary i
think um
you know do you eat your veggies
yes yes you get eight hours of sleep a
day um you know he flosses
he flosses okay
but what about your teeth
pretty good
yeah okay you call your mom
yeah that was good
okay um let's let's think let's say
you've gone
yes you know
in your intro i gave you different
classes for like
you know scrub mentality 101 iron banner
212. i'm pretty sure i'm in kindergarten
right now so this is going over real
well thanks okay okay kindergarten
really so uh
this is forward you know you go up here
you you move around with the right stick
here
oh okay okay okay lots of keyboards
there
hold on where's my spare keyboard okay
okay so here's all right w
yep okay yeah okay
a is to go left
what's this one dude what's the big bar
in the bottom i gotta know uh that's
called shatter dive it's really really
useful
it's it's really it's it's it's we're
not gonna get there we're not gonna get
there right now okay okay because that's
a skill move okay oh okay we need to get
you we need to get you
up and going with the basics okay so
you're doing great you're doing great
you're doing really really well i'm
gonna make sure you get a sticker at the
end of this but you know we need to we
need to go in increments i want my
ribbon is it blue
no no no no no no no
you get your ribbon once you graduate
okay i like that i like that it's
important all right it's important
okay
seriously
you know what's my my biggest tip for
people who are uh aside from two second
row 46 year old that
is to find weapons you're comfortable
with meta be damned and stick with them
because
when you are trying to get good
like think about all the things you need
to get good at you need to get good at
your positioning obviously you need to
get good at reading the map like
understanding how the map plays you need
to get good at reading your radar you
need to get good at using your abilities
in the right place at the right time
you need to get good at
timing your supers you have to get good
at
taking advantage of of opponents doing
whatever it is they do
you know and you have to be aware of of
just your general presence and whether
or not you're in danger whether you're
not you're far from your team there's a
whole lot of [ __ ] to think about pardon
my french you're good
and
you can't do any of that
if you're using weapons you're not
comfortable with
reach like if you if the if the like the
first
it's like trying to run a marathon and
shoes you haven't even worn before yes
good point cause you gotta bring it into
it
you have to break them in you have to
you have to break in your play style you
have to break in your own sense of self
in the crucible by using weapons that
that you're comfortable with and the
best way to do that obviously is in pve
that's the best way to get comfortable
with the weapons like that you have
so until you can do that until you can
crucially not only just feel comfortable
with your weapons but actually be able
to hit body shots reliably the forget
crits for a second but just being able
to to body shop people
without thinking
that's that's the step one and then we
can start thinking about all the all the
other ways which you need to improve you
have a super chat i know gaming forte
over here time stop picking on ivantis
he's so right nobody you're so right
because it's funny
i'm not i know what the meta is i know a
lot of people right now vex is the rage
and i get it vex is out here
and it was doing work but like i am so
comfortable
with my messenger but surprised when i
get crap on uh from a lot of teammates
they're like why are you using lord of
wolves
i'm just comfortable like it it's
it's not meta i mean it's good but i
would say it's not meta and it's
something about i've clutched up so many
times
when there were situations where people
were closing i i'm terrible when people
close dishes on me fast
like where like these hunters they're
all over the place i'm i'm up and i'm
like where and then they they tone down
on me and it's a wrap
and there's something about lord i could
just
backpedal or be aggressive and i have a
good range with it and i've gotten so
many kills with it and it's like i can't
peel it off because it's like it's it's
you made a good point like when you were
comfortable with something and then you
have success it reaffi it reinforces it
mentally positive reinforcement yeah
absolutely and now i can't take it off
because it's my safety net that's my
baby
this has helped me through tough times
you know that kind of thing and it may
not be the number one meta in this spot
but i i do good with it i like it shout
out to angry for calling me out
hardcore i missed my go figure but that
was like that was one of my babies in
crucible for a while because
it arranged the feel and like my role as
well i just i felt like i could hit
shots that i shouldn't be able to and
there were moments where i was like i
i was doing things in my head i'm like
it feels good i feel like i shouldn't
even be doing this with this weapon but
it felt good and that was one of mine
that got stripped from me sadly but
pulse is upsetting you didn't like
sunset again
that was if we're going to go down this
argument but yes but i mean that's kind
of thing it is 100 true like don't be
like oh you need to use messenger with
desperado
you're like if that weapon fires too
slow you feel like you don't have enough
way it's like find what works for you
honestly like i saw a cool guy talk
about skate lock
the fact that that thing is actually
back i know it's an auto rifle and half
of this podcast probably hates out our
efforts but
i know cog does
i don't hate around just don't feel they
should be the i don't i just don't feel
it should be the top but i don't think
so you can't hate auto rifles
i'm not a best guy i i purposely go
against i don't use people oh my god
crushing it bro it's if i'm i'm weird
like that where i don't know if no man
can relate to this like
i'm anti-meta when everybody's using it
i'm like i don't want to use it like it
feels like the cheat button i know i
should i probably would do better
actually i know why i don't use it the
reason why i don't use it because i
can't use load of wolves if i use it but
i love lord of wolves and i don't have a
kinetic equivalent that i'm comfortable
and for me i don't have a good you know
uh
shotgun or uh what you call it uh sfgs
which i like that are in the kinetic
spot maybe you guys can help me but they
help cog with a good kinetic equivalent
to use with vex because i prefer to be
honest nah i can't i prefer messenger
because it's something that you're doing
philosophy race walker astral horizon
fractalist i don't have a horizon what
fraction is this world you going with
though i do have a bunch of practices
so the common knowledge or common
sentiment would suggest something would
slide shot an opening shot
um i don't think you have to spec into
range that hard it definitely improves
the consistency of it but since
precisions are range capped at six to
six and a half meters
it doesn't really matter
i would like slide shots very handy
opening shot's very handy quick draw is
really handy i really
i would
just because yeah just because i mean
vex can kind of handle short range but
yes um you know you for those moments
where you're not quite sure whip it out
quickly and then you're off to the races
the thing with me is to not to cut you
was just that it's something i know you
ever have web e could probably relate to
this you have weapons that are meta but
they're like when you use them you're
trash
oh that's how absolutely yeah that's how
i feel with precision shotguns everybody
else maps me across the map with
practices and chaperones oh that's not a
slug chaperone is but fractures yeah
yeah but when i use it
it's like
hey oh you how you gonna hit me with the
gate good how you doing
i saw that
i'm sorry bro i just can't get those
one-hit kills like everybody else
the only time i was able to do that was
with um what was the reign of the um
what was the shotgun that they nerfed
that was the bar of everybody's
existence legendary solar
fell
if y'all had a fell with his equivalent
it's something about that that that
style shotgun i can't i can't use it
the trial shotgun is actually pretty
close
i don't have it in australia yeah yeah i
don't have astronauts
they got sunset okay that actually
wasn't though
i i say just stick with felwinters
because like if it's working for you
it's right for you and i'm like the
opposite i hate it when people nitpick
over other people's loadouts it's like
yeah you know i never look at other
people's like armor mods i never look at
other people's loadouts i just want to
know if it's working for you
roll with it if it isn't working for you
you got to change something uh because
it's you know it's not working but uh
yeah if it fell into or sorry if uh if
lord of wolves is working for you yeah i
just i just bro the loadout is too
dominant for me because what happens is
if i proc again stopping my apes with
with uh with a load of wolves but if i
proc desperate i put a clip up i don't
know if y'all saw e
i clutch
bro i was the whole team's down it's 3v1
i got desperado to proc and i had my
little ark buddies with me with my
getaway artist they were snitching
telling me they was that
it was a good boy it was a good day man
i felt dominant when i feel that's wrong
i get cocky i look for them
well yeah
that's how i get with desperado so it's
that combination just sits so perfect
for me right now so it is what it is
i love that you call call outs snitching
that is my favorite i'm for sure i'm for
sure going to be using that terminology
now when i run trials and be like hey
let's let's remember to remember to do
your your snitching remember to do
everybody snitches snitches everybody
instead of killing you're going to be
getting stitches in here what up bonus
points bonus points of all three of you
run rat king
oh even better yeah because you're a rat
get it yeah
very volatile right
won't be able to run it because i can't
but
that's a byproduct of not exploring your
own comfortability your your own comfort
with different play styles with
different archetypes of weapon i had
this issue all the time like i would
i think in destiny 1 i was a hand cannon
main for sure and i i was hand cannon
snipe main and i didn't dare pick up
like a clever dragon even though i knew
trade i didn't try a 900
rpm auto rifle from trials until it
became like the most unavoidable option
to use
and every single time i would suck with
it for like
a week
to two weeks and then i would be okay
with it but just okay i wouldn't be
actually very very good with it and the
people who who
can pick up anything and just run with
it they've got enough of a repository of
data of other similar weapons that have
worked this way
that
they can draw upon and then they they
take that knowledge and they adapt it
and apply it and obviously spend a [ __ ]
ton of time in the crucible
uh adapting to the weapon just adapt
lmao
but yeah like i honestly i wouldn't feel
too bad about it because in the grand
scheme of things if you're struggling
with using the meta options it's not the
worst thing in the world because right
now the sandboxes yeah i'm
sorry travis it's kind of balanced
it's actually kind of really well
balanced right now i've heard that from
multiple people like that it's probably
in one of the better states yeah in the
grand scheme of destiny for like times
it's in a decent place i've heard so the
fastest primary uh right now is the
peace bond sidearm 0.5 i'm going to give
you something
i have which is which is balanced
because it's you know like you have to
be here to kill someone um
in terms of the like the mid-range
primaries uh 340 rpm pulse rifles are
0.67 time to kill they're the fastest
and then the slowest one is a 120 rpm
hand cannon a 1.0 time to kill but then
you don't do straight fights with 120s
you use cover and you peek out of cover
and all that
um the worst archetypes are like on
paper the worst archetypes are probably
scout rifles but you know who cares
that's normal this car rifles
but everything else where you lose me on
the it's kind of balanced
that's map design and also think of how
crap crucible would be if it was all
scout rifles oh for sure yeah before and
it's not
yeah so everything else is within 0.7 to
0.93
ttk and that really is the difference
vex method class is a 0.77
really
which is the same
which is the same time skill as a 720
rpm auto rifle which is like kramer rush
really well there's also like you know
what i'm saying a lot like in trials
especially in end matches was like uh
you know the linear the linear fusion
rifle
is the new exotic one
lorenzo
doesn't feel balanced to me and yeah
yeah the new uh the new void uh fusion
rifle as well like i i think some of
those are a little strange like the yeah
no for sure they're not any any crazier
than sniper rifles but their ttk is
instant right they get the shot off it's
like they got a very high assist yeah
versus like a sniper but there's the
charge time the placing and stuff like
yeah i got definitely picked off a few
times but after a little while i was
like i just can't like don't stand still
dumbass like that stuff i'm telling
myself if i get hit with that i'm like i
think that's a little on me so so for me
the the biggest indicator of what is an
outlier is usually trial support if
there's good data and obviously because
of this we can we had amazing data
um
vex mythoclast
is like nearly double the next
one on the list which is the messenger
and
which is crazy considering a lot of
people do not have it that's the other
right right that's the huge thing
see to me
the vex gets scary after the first kill
because the damage profile completely
changes ash baby messages what what it
really the reason why vex is meta is
because people don't know how to
position themselves for [ __ ]
that's my take on it it's like terrible
you have to be
like if you die to an auto rifle you're
out in the open or maybe you peaked at
the wrong time but for vex to have this
much dominance i imagine this is mostly
console driven because on pc
it's it's good but i don't see it as
much as like 140s quite really yeah i'm
on console and it's just everywhere dude
like that's just everything yeah it was
like pc yeah i'm getting a lot of cheap
kills people walking down to the open
right yeah
yeah and then after that and after that
i think the the time to kill goes down
to like a point seven or a point six
seven or something like that and that's
just very hard to to deal with no matter
how good you're and then i activate my
alternate fire mode and i just blast
people there you go nice yeah
no no matt what's the top three
primaries right now
messenger ace
yes yeah so vex messages
yeah ace is good he's still good okay
okay i just want to get the idea okay
cool followed by the darkest before yeah
we're not calling yeah
shotguns surprise surprise yeah can we
talk about the dirty secret in the room
y'all pvp
sorry
um
i don't know if it's um basically a
stasis build where guys are putting up
the walls pre-match
and then they shatter them get the uh
the stasis fragment that gives them the
overshield and then you have to face
them with the overshield like that's
pretty messy man that's crazy that is
whisper of rhyme and i'm sorry to say
that i helped contribute to the problem
because i made a video on it no bad no
if you have a full overshield with
whisper of rhyme which you can get very
easily if you're on hunter you can tank
a headshot from a aggressive sniper
rifle like a frozen orbit bro
i was facing teams of those
it is intimidating when they come out
from behind that wall that states well
now it only lasts 10 seconds so by the
time they get to you they'll have the
overshield but they only have a couple
of seconds of it so you just kind of you
see it and you're like up just bounce
out okay
what are they doing they were literally
putting up walls and then i'm like what
is happening and why do they have
overshields that that build yeah it was
crazy i've not seen that that's that's
nuts though
entire teams i would see it doing it
there you go travis use up for your
tuesday morning runs
i will yeah after the five loss friday
yeah
uh you've got to make sure you're not on
that list
that's that's that's what we call it we
call uh the five loss friday and the
tuesday morning triumphs
salute
well thank you guys for all the lessons
i've got this recorded so i can go back
and learn got my note my yellow legal
pad taking notes
i'm good to go for remember remember
shatter guy
skill option gotcha
and the stickers
i'll give you a tutorial next time i'm
on the show
see you next
[Laughter]
i love week and this has been let's help
ibontos
a long running segment long running
segment yeah
that's the best part is because he was
all into like oh let's make this a
segment second time our lawn writing
long running segment i'm like dude it's
been one time
like stop trying to make fetch happen
come on
it's called bootstrapping okay it's uh
i'm trying to
make it seem like it's legit it's good
because i was i was really curious about
what this long running segment was
was it worth it was it worth the wait
the ties
yeah i i wear the ties people think that
i'm serious and then they hear me talk
and they're like who is this guy i
thought he was a reliable source of
information
yeah that's great
you're on the internet that's all the
reliability you need these days that's
it man that's it
i have a twitter account
that's pretty much all you need well the
last thing i wanted to cover uh just
because we got about 15 minutes before
this man goes to have dinner with his
wife
um
wife girlfriend girlfriend
jesus she's been hounding me on that oh
[Laughter]
she'll never listen to this for yourself
yeah no she will 100 listen to this
often especially after i tell her that
yeah
anyways
no i was going to say um before we let
you go uh just the season has been
awesome for story lore everything going
on with the shadows realm so i wanted to
touch on this week with the shattered
realm now we got really the opening of
the metroidvania we got to go in the
everything going on at savathune and
just the story beats this week so
whoever wants to jump in first
um it's been a very exciting season so
far and we're four weeks in so i'm
curious where it goes but who wants to
like what was your best take this week
from all the story or
travis's
eyebrows to stop reading yeah so travis
is ready okay yeah eyebrows need to need
to stay uh yeah i think i'm i think i'm
now
willing to officially state the thing i
said two weeks ago that i thought this
might be the best season uh the best
offseason non-main expansion season i
think i think it is i really do i think
the way that they've the way they've
done the time gates and the metroidvania
style and now and this week we're
getting to go back and solve all the
mysteries and seeing what those
mysteries were this week with the secret
boss fights and that sort of stuff i'm
just like yeah like i can see myself
playing through all six weeks and not
being bored does the six person activity
matter to me no like i hate doing it but
i've hated that for every season so like
i you know i none of those those six
person matchmaking activities have
really stuck out to me so um i just
think like the story beats those
one-on-one conversations with sabathune
the cut scenes we got another one this
week that was really awesome all that
stuff i'm just like dude this is the
best season like easily for me so and
now with all the pvp stuff that's going
on like how can you not be stoked about
destiny right now this is like the best
thing they could do leading up to the
witch queen because i'm already feeling
the hype even though it's still like six
months out so yeah i'm i'm willing to
say this is the best uh my personal
season so far
of destiny what i loved it but what i
love about the narrative this season
without spoiling anything or in case
somebody hasn't done it like me i
haven't done all of it i don't spoil it
for myself um
you know just the fact that every single
character this season whether they're in
front of you or if they're on the
periphery everyone has motivations and
everyone has a very like everyone it
feels like everybody's
got stakes that are increasingly ramping
up and they all matter and everybody's
like
like they're like i'm worried that we're
gonna have several people die at the end
of the season i
don't think everybody's going to come
out of this season
that's my thing i think she's she's gone
after i said that i said that a couple
of weeks ago and everybody flamed me and
was like there's no way they would kill
her off i'm like i think she
there's there's a lot of uh
circumstantial evidence i don't know if
you guys have been watching milo and
stuff but he thinks osiris is going to
die oh um but i think that's a little
bit if he's not sure for sure yeah yeah
if he's not already dead
but whatever we'll see we'll see but
basically yeah it it it's just sort of
like
this week the screws are being turned a
little bit
and you're starting to see oh this is
where it could be going oh we don't know
how it's going but you can see where
this you can see that this is gonna lead
to a huge moment and that huge moment is
gonna kick off the witch queen so i
really love just the little
things they're doing week by week just
to
ratchet up the tension
yeah i mean it's hard to debate trav on
this because
you know i'm a person that i i come in
with
a reasonable expectation each season and
prior to this i would say what season of
the dawn was a favorite of mine i think
season arrival started strong and then
it kind of faded out but um
this has been
amazing you know it's really has been
you know the actual alignment activity
is different not everyone's cup of tea
but it's okay for me but i i look
forward to and i had to shout out the
dad of t today i hit up tom and um shout
out to rachel levine from lore
i don't know about y'all but i it gives
makes me uncomfortable it makes it gives
me a chilling feel when it says you
finish the steps for the week and it's
like
your friend sabathune wants to see the
guardian you
i don't know why i get you her
girlfriend burger
yeah it makes me uncomfortable bro i
like even walking into that room and i
know she's encased in like i i keep my
character a couple steps back when i
talk
like she makes me a cuddle but it's
she's just
very chilling
with
her description of the truth
you know i i think it's very well done
i'm not going to spoil it wilson is
doing an awesome job yeah oh my gosh
she's amazing and it's like the other
thing is you know how you know i'm sorry
i'll let you finish no no please you
know how uh everybody was saying oh you
know what the fact that we know what
happens the next season completely ruins
it i think the opposite is true yeah i
think i agree yoshi wins
everything that's happening right now
feel like oh we're about to do something
real bad
i kind of like that we know yeah it
raises the stakes it's like this get get
it
there's no way they don't win at the end
right but the journey on the way there
is special especially and i know like i
said i know this has been a little thing
back and forth with me in terms of
marketing and stuff like that but i
gotta agree with trav i gotta know that
that the fact that we know
somehow she's getting out of this and
somehow she's going to manipulate
everybody to get her end gamer end goal
is chilling because she seems like
there's no way but the thing for me
again not to spoil because i know a lot
of people haven't done it the crow
dynamic for me this week is really
interesting yes that's the biggest
domino yeah like it just from a
manipulation standpoint
from a lore standpoint even
you know when you go through this quest
i'm caught up on the quest now what is
it the uh the i got accepted um
yes
listening to him as
aldrin and and getting stuff from there
sorry
sorry but i hopefully i didn't say too
much but at the end of the day
dumbledore
apologies my brother apologize wow that
was a rough one by the way nobody hadn't
got that anyways yeah
yeah yeah get get the exotic weapon get
the anxiety weapon very very well done
and we're just you know we're gonna see
what happens here we're gonna see
exactly what happens this is setting up
to be amazing and i think for me the
ultimate reason why
is i said it before the dreaming city
is one of the greatest set pieces
they've ever done it's something about
that the lore the aesthetic
it's just the everything about it i love
and i like that it's taking place here
we're getting to use because they really
didn't use it enough after forsaken and
we're getting in i just love it so this
is this is great and like uh travis said
with the whole metroidvania with the
shattered realm
well done each time and they finally you
know released the whole let us store
more of the parallax trajectory thing so
that we can unlock more of this stuff
the webinars have been good it's been
great it's been great pvp's in a good
place so far so good i just want to see
how they put a bow on it and where they
go with it to lead up to which queen but
i am thoroughly enjoying it every week e
yeah no i mean you guys said most
everything i've been thinking of i don't
obviously spoil what happened this week
um nomad there is a cool cinematic so
definitely make sure you watch it
um
that's all i'm going to say uh it goes
along with doing a quest
the reason i haven't uh
done it yet is because i was making you
some videos on how to get better
there you go he's taking the whole time
i didn't play destiny on tuesday or
wednesday just because i was working on
videos
just for me i appreciate that yeah well
in fairness i made the video so you can
get through them faster so you'll be
done in no time
thanks in fairness i haven't seen the
cinema either i'm still at the final
step of acquiring said thing so i
haven't spoiled anything because i
really haven't seen what they talk about
so i don't know what it is
but yeah i mean seeing what they have
done with the shattered realm and the
metroidvania of the unlocks and things
like that and there's still one more
thing that we're going to get that's
going to get a little bit more
um the way we explored the zone this
time around the way we could like
really use the different abilities and
then finally we'll see where this you
know the safe passage works a little bit
longer all of that's been excellent to
go through and as you said like whether
it's repeating it's not like going back
through all the corrupted version it's
like they've they've taken these like
seasonal activities because like expunge
and you had corrupted expunge you're
like yeah that's a little tweak this
time you've got like hey here's the same
thing now you can explore like twice as
much and i'm like that's
like people i mean you can think about
in curse of osiris we got mercury yeah
we got the infinite forest and all the
repetitions in there but the fact that
in a season we got three these three
different just very well interconnected
i mean you're sitting there almost
playing dark souls when i popped out of
one of these things yeah if you if you
know what reminds me of big time is when
shattered throne came out for the first
time
the hell is this this today i spent 45
minutes in one shattered realm because i
was just like trying to find all the
pathways it's amazing it's amazing it
really is and and i know e i was
thinking about you because i know how
much
you love um you know the shattered realm
the dungeon and and that whole bit and
it has certain little mechanics and
aspects of it that is cool and i guess i
watched your video because i get i
purposely waited to not do the quest the
exotic quest until all steps seem to be
released now and um i was doing your
videos i was like wow this is this is
really cool just going through all of
this and the anchors and they just
really did a good job of utilizing the
space in a new creative way and making
it fun yep and then as you guys have
said like the story the lore the beats
that have been the dominoes that
savathun is setting up you can feel like
literally the tension between a couple
different characters what mara's trying
to do what she has done in the past to
aldrin you'll see
uh where crow is at now you've got petra
stand in the middle of some of this
stuff osiris is sitting on the outer
wings
saint is trying to go look for osir all
these pieces are going on as we lead
into what is supposed to be
i went back and i was looking at
something like the campaign for which
queen is supposed to be something like
we've never had
and they're here running on these
cylinders right now
if they put something together for the
witch queen that is firing like this i'm
just going to be blown away fire and i'm
just going to just i'm going to throw
this out you know ever since travis
became a regular on the show destiny's
been killing it
coincidence
that's right i still gotta work on the i
gotta get somebody to do the art for
that but yeah we'll get you there on a
new updated the rodeo
jesus
uh but as we hit our time i do kind of
want to wrap this thing up since um the
big stuff we want to talk about is
crucible uh if you guys are listening to
this maybe this occupy your ears for a
couple couple hours while you are
playing trials this weekend but it's a
lot of fun the season's in a great spot
and honestly it's a good
probably one of the best times to be a
destiny person
because of where we are at right now and
what we get to look forward to in the
future
it's it's bright there's gonna be some
downtime and i am totally fine with that
because my backlog is full but for the
moment man it is a lot of fun every week
to log in see what's going on and then
now you can actually look forward to the
week and be like
hey i can i can play some i can play
some trials this weekend and i'm like
that's a sentence i can say now that's
so weird
that's so weird real quick really really
annoying that they're doing the new
trials objective mode right during the
halo infinite technical preview i'm very
annoying no i don't i know i don't think
i'm going to play it dude because i
gotta get my halo in i will always
i'll be i'll be there friday reset but
then after that and after that yeah one
quick day halo's yeah it's going down
all right well as we go we always got to
make sure we give our guests plenty of
time to shout out all that stuff that's
got going on if you have not found
listened to seen this man anywhere else
before
i hope we have opened your eyes to go
look for our guest but sir the floor is
yours where can they find you what can
they expect how can they chat with you
probably leave his dms alone but
everything else what do you got
um no thank you very much for having me
and
and
having me back more importantly it's
very rare to be invited to one of these
things let alone being invited twice so
thank you for giving me the time of your
platform i really appreciate that
you guys can find me on youtube
primarily youtube.com for slash
ascendant nomad or just search ascendant
nomad and i'll come up
um i'm on twitter as well by the same
name twitch by the same name and i have
a discord server with
the same name so
um yeah i'm online but i if you want to
see what i'm really all about don't go
to my twitter it's just full of pvp
nonsense and and engagement farming as
is the case with most content creators
these days
um but uh yeah my my good stuff is on
youtube
legend
travis are you uh under locking key
until your stuff gets out
i'm good i i yeah you can read my
articles reviews and previews on ign.com
uh this week i'm reviewing uh sable uh
which is an indie game that's i got a
very interesting art style um and then
you can also find me on uh bitcast on
sunday mornings at 8 a.m pacific or
where we talk about general gaming stuff
with my buddy aims ains and uh this old
uh old guy
he sort of just wandered into the show
and i guess they didn't see it
so yeah you can find me there
[ __ ] how about you what do you got going
on oh done salute first i guess look to
the nomad it's always a pleasure to hear
his perspectives keeping the pvp
community alive
teaching him this in his spare time it's
just he's just multiple somebody's got
to do it so i'm glad to have some
teachers out there
i respect all the hats he wears you know
this is a make-a-wish program helping
one one lucky non-pvp skilled person
yeah you are great and i know i hyped
you up but i don't think that would be
my make-a-wish i'm sorry
absolutely man pleasure having you back
perfect time to have a bad obviously pvp
discussion all the great stuff and uh
travis and the whole me and e but yeah
man you already know what it is with me
defining dude you can catch that up we
got some two episodes up we got an
ultimate up talking about the whole
disney ip stuff so check that out and if
you don't want to you know do the whole
patreon thing you can wait it's our last
stand media for free 99 we got a great
uh discussion with ben smith the mayor
and some great topics in the xbox
community and then of course every
sunday is the lord's day 11 a.m nfl
friendly time so you can go check that
out exactly sorry
yeah i suppose funny i spoke no to
thank god
no no competition we keep our slot so
you guys are
going are you guys earlier now yeah
yeah just for football just before i
told oh what you call it aids about this
he was like now it's cool because we're
only gonna be there for like two bucks
and then once everybody's team is out of
contention in january we'll we'll move
back to our world
you know
we squeaked out a win once we'll see if
that keeps going but yeah that would be
that was tragic almost lost so catch
iron podcast with the lords oh like i
said on sunday 11 a.m this weekend we
will have jimmy champagne jimmy
champagne we'll pull up we'll talk some
tech with him and should be great and of
course we got that last word podcast on
thursdays which i love my man travis e
and we got to get some new artwork
because we got to put a tie in there
somewhere
and get this popping but yeah man
absolute pleasure and look everybody
that pulled up today it was really cool
to see everybody in the chat and
engaging with us whether they agree or
disagree it's always fun and e which got
going uh for me uh as you guys know
death loop i've been playing that one on
stream hooks are going to be heavy on
that one it is so
as i said i've never played an arcane
game but man i get it like this may be
like a polished version of the other two
but something just about the little joy
of playing around in the sandbox i just
cannot i'm like even thinking right now
i'm like do i stream again tonight just
to go play around in it some more uh and
then kind of birds of spirits that comes
out on tuesday i've been waiting a long
time since i saw that preview
uh and the new world is not long after i
don't know if i'm gonna dabble in that
one or not but again
that's a hole that's a whole thing like
i haven't played an mmo like that in so
long i don't even know if i can squeeze
that in but overall
it's been a lot of fun but the biggest
thing is uh nomad the pleasure has been
absolutely ours so thank you for
spending the time with us you are always
welcome back sir it is a pleasure to
have you and a pleasure to chat and as
most people know it's easy to listen to
you talk man so we we don't mind letting
you
it's it's good times but for this
episode number 166 thank you guys i
think we cracked over 100 of you guys
watching out there so appreciate that
one you guys blowing it up on the
youtube so glad you guys are supporting
the new night uh but for this episode
number 166 september 16th with our
amazing guest it has been
the last word